Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¿Está girando hacia ti o se aleja?
No hay acuerdo.
Ella es el tema misterioso del
maestro holandés Johannes Vermeer,
"La joven de la perla",
una pintura que se suele llamar
"La Mona Lisa del norte".
En un estilo holandés de pinturas
idealizadas, a veces demasiado expresivas,
conocido como tronies,
"La joven de la perla" tiene el encanto
y la característica sutileza
de la obra de Vermeer.
Pero esta pintura se distingue de
las escenas narrativas tranquilas
que observamos de lejos en muchas
de las pinturas de Vermeer.
Una joven que lee una carta.
Una clase de piano.
Un artista del retrato en acción.
Estas pinturas nos dan un sentido de
intimidad, manteniendo su distancia,
una cortina corrida a menudo
hace hincapié en la separación.
Podemos presenciar una lechera que vierte
serenamente un tazón de leche,
pero esa leche no es para nosotros.
Somos solo espectadores.
La composición estudiada
en las pinturas de Vermeer
invoca una armonía equilibrada.
Con el piso a cuadros
en muchas de sus obras,
Vermeer demuestra su maestría
en la perspectiva y el escorzo.
Es una técnica que usa la distorsión
para dar la ilusión de un objeto
que se aleja en la distancia.
Otros elementos, como las líneas
de visión, espejos y fuentes de luz
describen el momento mediante
el espacio y la posición.
La mujer que lee una carta
en una ventana abierta
está ubicada precisamente para que la
ventana refleje su imagen al espectador.
Vermeer ocultó la pata de un caballete
en aras de la composición.
La ausencia de estos mismos elementos
dan vida a "La joven de la perla".
El tratamiento que Vermeer da a la luz
y a la sombra, el claroscuro,
usa un fondo oscuro, plano, para poner
de relieve su tridimensionalidad.
En vez de ser como la escenografía
de una escena narrativa teatral,
se torna un sujeto psicológico.
El contacto visual y sus labios
entreabiertos, como a punto de decir algo,
nos atraen a su mirada.
Temas tradicionales del retrato eran a
menudo figuras de nobleza o religiosas.
Entonces ¿por qué Vermeer
pintó una joven anónima?
En el siglo XVII, la ciudad de Delft,
como los Países Bajos, en general,
se había vuelto contra la aristocracia
gobernante y la iglesia católica.
Tras ocho décadas de rebelión
contra el poder español,
los holandeses favorecerieron la idea
del autogobierno y una república política.
Ciudades como Delft no eran
supervisadas por reyes u obispos,
por eso artistas como Vermeer
se quedaron sin clientes tradicionales.
Afortunadamente, la innovación empresarial
encabezada por la Compañía Holandesa
de las Indias Orientales
transformó el panorama económico
en los Países Bajos.
Creó una clase mercantil
y un nuevo tipo de patrón
que deseaba ser representado
en las pinturas que financiaba.
Estos comerciantes preferían
sujetos de clase media
representados en espacios que
parecían sus propios hogares,
rodeados de objetos familiares.
Los mapas que aparecen en las pinturas
de Vermeer, por ejemplo,
eran considerados mundanos y a la moda
por los comerciantes de lo que se conoce
como la Edad de Oro Holandesa.
El turbante oriental que lleva
"La joven de la perla"
también hace hincapié en la mundanidad
de la clase comerciante,
y la perla en sí, un símbolo de riqueza,
es en realidad una exageración.
Vermeer no se podría haber permitido
una perla de ese tamaño.
Quizá fue una cuenta de vidrio o de lata
barnizada para que pareciera una perla.
Este espejismo de la riqueza
se refleja en la propia pintura.
En un contexto más amplio, aparece
la perla redonda y pesada,
pero una vista detallada muestra que es
solo una mancha que flota en la pintura.
Un examen minucioso, recuerda el poder
de Vermeer como creador de ilusiones.
Quizá nunca conozcamos la verdadera
identidad de "La joven de la perla",
pero podemos abordar su retrato
de una manera inolvidable.
Desde su hogar permanente en
el Museo Mauritshuis en La Haya,
su presencia es a la vez
penetrante y sutil.
A su manera enigmática, representa
el nacimiento de una perspectiva moderna
sobre la economía, la política y el amor.